Es ist ein geschäft mit dem tod zumindest die fernsehmoderatorin miriam pielhau bei einem wirkungslosen
krebsmittel aufgesessen und hatte alle hoffnungen darauf gesetzt
diese hoffnung war trügerisch sie hatte studien über die wirksamkeit in fachmagazinen im internet gefunden alles wirkte total seriös
das geschäft mit diesen nicht
wissenschaftlichen studien ist ein millionengeschäft und miriam pielhau eines ihrer opfer klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Es war mir ein bisschen peinlich im fahrradgeschäft sprach mich eine frau an und meinte da für uns kennen miriam pielhau
schaltete ich im nachhinein ich hatte sie wegen ihrer kurzen haaren nicht erkannt das war kurz vor ihrem tod hier in berlin
damals sagt sie sind noch in interviews dass sie geheilt sei wenige wochen später am 12 juli
2016 starb sie dann das hat mich ziemlich vom hocker gehauen das jetzt allerdings ans tageslicht gekommen ist das ist dann richtig
verstörend miriam pielhau ist fake studien zu einem medikament aufgesetzten sie dachte dass sie
gcf geheilt hätte doch die studien zur wirkung waren
unwissenschaftlich und konnten die wirkung gar nicht nachweisen so haben es jetzt recherchen von ndr wdr und
süddeutscher zeitung ergeben erschienen sind die studien zum beispiel im verlags 1 publications was viele wissenschaftler
wissenschaftlerin nicht wissen hier werden die publikationen nicht peer reviewed das heißt es gucken keine
fachwissenschaftler und fast fach wissenschaftlerinnen über die studien- und bewerten sie sondern das findet einfach nicht statt sie werden ungeprüft
veröffentlicht die schuldigen so geht sie macht hätten es nie in eine seriöse publikation geschafft dort sehen experten
experten über die studien- und wären in diesem fall wohl schnell über schwere methodische mängel gestolpert für laien aber auch für fachleute
ist das aber nicht auf den ersten blick erkennt dich also ist nicht auf den ersten blick klar dass diese magazine
nicht seriös sind und so hat dieses geschäftsgebaren
dramatische folgen erstens es werden wissenschaftliche studien veröffentlicht die keinen gehalt haben zweitens
wissenschaftler und wissenschaftlerinnen veröffentlichen in diesem umfeld auch seriöse wissenschaftliche studien ohne es zu ahnen die
feldstudien bekommen so eine hohe glaubwürdigkeit
drittens und das ist wohl das schlimmste aus den falschen studien wird zum teil sogar in
seriösen studien zitiert so findet die fake wissenschaft ihrem weg in die seriöse wissenschaft absolut katastrophal
und die ausmaße sind unglaublich nach den recherchen von wdr ndr und süddeutscher zeitung haben alleine in deutschland
5000 wissenschaftler und wissenschaftlerinnen in solchen fällen zahlen veröffentlicht sie setzen ihre studien und ihrer
wissenschaftlichkeit damit jetzt erheblichen zweifeln aus und das sind nicht nur irgendwelche assistentinnen oder assistentin in der zweiten reihe auch renommierte
professoren und professorinnen
sind darauf reingefallen sie finden jetzt ihre studien neben
unwissenschaftlichen papieren von klimaskeptikern
und studien her von herstellern dubioser medikamente gegen krebs
autismus und parken sondern auch wir werden hier stärker auf die quellen achten und nicht mehr
jede zehnte studio schokolade isst gesund ist nicht gesund ist gesund und so weiter sofort veröffentlichen also wenn ihr kein video zu
seriösen studien mehr hier verpassen wollt dann hättet mich bei whatsapp dann geht er die kaputte avaloq sie auf youtube und verpasst kein video mehr
denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir persönlich von jedem upload und
zwar noch vor allen anderen täglich garantiert einfach hier draufklicken und am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal kriegs um social media abonnieren
da gibt es das neueste aus der social media welt dafür hier klicken aber nicht die
genau die glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter
mit dafür auch draufklicken fake news in der wissenschaft ja da geht es um eine feldstudie dies sogar in die seriöse times
geschafft hatte bis dann